ilk
[Alkış]
öncelikle hepiniz hoşgeldiniz biz
gerçekten çok güzel sınırları izledik
Hepsi birbirinden değerli de evet çok
heyecan verici bir günde buradayız Ben
İstanbul Fatih'te
Edirnekapı'da küçük bir dairede dünyaya
geldim ailemin tek kız çocuğuyum şanslı
azınlıklardan biri olduğum söylenemez
hayattaki en önemli şanssızlığım zaten
bayan olmamla başladı diyebilirim Çünkü
babam tam anlamıyla bir erkek çocuğu
delisi dedi Belki yaptığı meslek gereği
ip Berke
bulunduğu Türk toplumu ve çevre gereği
erkek çocuğu Özdemir içerisinde
senelerini geçirdi ben
o hayatıma ilk adım attığımda Bir
yaşındaydım bir yaşında yürümek benim
için çok önemli ve büyük bir adım da ve
belki Hayatımın en zor
dönemlerinden Bir tanesiyle Çünkü her
zaman için o adım kadar büyük adımlar
atmak zorunda kaldım Hayatımın her
alanında mücadele etmek zorunda kaldım
şu bunlar bu süreçte yani ilkokul
döneminde üç tane okul değiştirerek
devam etti Çünkü annem eğitimci olduğu
için hiçbir okula
okullarda verilen eğitimleri
değerlendirip bir şekilde Benim daha
farklı bir okula adapte olmam
gerektiğini düşünüp bana destek olmak
adına bu tarzda bir girişimlerde
bulunuyordu üç tane okul değiştirdikten
sonra en sonunda başka bir ileti başka
bir ilçeye taşındık ve o taşındığımız
yerde bir tane Ortaokulu bu ve orta
okula başladığımda ilk sıraya girdim ve
sırada Bir tane arkadaşım geldi yanıma
tabi O zaman arkadaş değiliz Seninle
arkadaş olabilir miyiz dedi Ben de böyle
zaten hani İçine kapanık daha böyleyse
işte ve çok fazla dışarıda oynamayan
Annemle beraber olan sürekli vakit
geçiren bir kız çocuğu olarak tabi dedim
ve orta okul hayatımız üç sene boyunca
Onunla beraber geçtim bir gün evde
oturuyoruz Tabii o zamanlar televizyonda
çok kısıtlı şeyler var çok farklı
dijital hiçbir şey yok bilgisayar yok
Telefonumuz yok E sadece eğlendiğimiz
şeyler kitaplar işte bir takım sınırlı
sayıda televizyon programları ve genelde
dışarıda oyun oynamakla geçiyor ve ders
çalışmakla geçiyor Annem geldi dedi ki
çocuklar dizisi ne yapıyorsunuz dedi
oturuyoruz Dedik Ona niye oturuyorsunuz
dedim o böyle cümle hayatın boyunca b ya
bekleyen Konfor alanından çıkmamızı
sağlayan cümlelerden en önemlisi oldu
dedik Ne yapalım dedi ki sizin listeniz
Yok burada dedi Biz devlet sesi yok
Sizinde de kapı kapı dolaşıp imza
toplayıp buraya bir devlet Lisesi
araştırmanız gerekiyor dedi peki dedik
Biz de çıktık giyindik başladık sokak
sokak dolaşmaya On yaşında iki kız
çocuğu sokak sokak dolaşan dolaşan on
binlerce imza topladık ve daha sonra
Aral lisemizin açılmasına bir vesile
olduk bu imzaları belediye ilettik
gerekli makamlara elektik ve Sağ
olsunlar onlar da sesimizi duydu ve
güzel bir okulumuz oldu güzel bir okul
kazandırdık o ilçe yap tabi ayak böyle
devam etmedi aynı dönemlerde işte
gidiyoruz Yine bir şeyler yapmaya
çalışıyoruz defter satıyoruz kalem
satıyoruz yani o teşvikle biz artık
kendi o buzdan çıkıp bir şekilde
yapabileceklerimiz in
limitlerinde farkettik ve bunu ümitleri
fark ederken bir baktık ki gerçekten
yeteri kadar çabaladığı mızda birçok
şeyi başarabilir hale geldi daha sonra
Liseyi bitirdikten sonra yine 17 yaşında
Çünkü Kredi sistemden dolayı bizim erken
bitirme şansımız vardı liseyi bitirdik
da hiçbir şekilde İngilizce bilmeden
ailem sağolsun alanların desteğiyle dedi
ki yine benim Yurtdışına gitmem
gerekiyor çünkü dünyayı görmeden dünyayı
algılama mümkün değil de dolayısıyla
aldım elime valizimi bindim uçağı da
otobüse binmem işim hayatımda şehirler
arası yolculuk neredeyse ailemin ağacın
hiç kimseyle yapmamışım uçağı zaten hiç
gülmemişim o dönemler uçak çok pahalı
Yine telefon yok hiçbir şey yok bindim
valize Ağlaya Ağlaya
ben direk
Amerika'ya gidiyorum İngilizce yok
hiçbir şey yok aldım valizimi ben
ailemden ayrıldım bir tek çocuk olarak
sonra uçakta şunu öğrendim Washington'a
gitmeyi hedefliyorum fakat Washington
Havaalanı Ne tesadüf ki greve giriyor ve
ben Atlanta havalarını iniyorum
Atlanta Havaalanı dünyanın en büyük
havaalanlarından bir tanesi gümrükten
geçmek zorundayım gümrükten geçmemiş
içinde çok az bir vaktim var daha sonra
iç hatları gideceğim hiçbir şey
bilmiyorum telefonum yok Ah Ondan sonra
dedim ki üç seçeneği mor Ebru'ya dedim
oturup ağlayacaksın kaderine küseceksin
ya dedim Gördükten geçip uçağı
yakalayacaksın ya da paran varsa bir
sonraki bilet alacaksın Tabii benim
Aslında tek bir seçeneğim vardı
dolayısıyla bir şekilde 30 dakika
içerisinde tren geçen bir havaalanından
gittim o vaşinqton değilse uçağına
bindim ve orada
1996-97 senelerinde ve Amazon ve iyi
beyin kuralım dönemleri ile karşılaştık
Dün Türkiye'ye döndükten sonra dedim ki
benim dedim e-ticaret Sitesi açmam
gerekiyor ve bütün Ayşe e-ticaretten
satılabilir hale getirmem gerekiyor
tabii ailecek böyle geniş bir aileyiz
arkadaşlarımız var şimdi dostumuza
dediler ki tek kız çocuğunu Amerika Lara
gönderirsen işte olacağı bu bu yani siz
ne yapacaksınız bilmiyorum dediler şimdi
Ağustos arkadaş Böylece ben dedim ki
hayır her şey internetten satılabilir
bunu yapabiliriz RC yedek parça
satabiliriz Yunus atabiliriz gazete
satabiliriz kitap satabiliriz her şey
satabilir diyorum Evet evet diyorlar
satabiliriz doğru işte neyse ben böyle o
dönemlerde artık dedim ki Tamam o zaman
şöyle bir şey yapabilirim dünyada olan
ankesörlü telefonlar var ve yurt dışını
arama yaparken arama kartları
kullanılıyor dedim ki Türkiye'de arama
kartları Yok ben ne yapabilirim
Türkiye'ye arama kartlarını Getirirsem
benim gibi yurtdışında ve onlara bir
fayda sağlamış olurum ve aileleriyle
rahat rahat konuşabilirler Çünkü ben
aramadığım zaman ailem bana ulaşamıyorum
Çünkü cep telefonu yok o dönemde Her
neyse arama kartları ile ilgili bir
takım girişimlerde bulundum ve sonucunda
Türkiye dünyanın en önemli arama
kartlarından bir tanesini getirdim büyük
Uluslararası bir firmayı Türkiye'deki
partnerleri ile tanıştığını ve Hayatımda
en önemli ilk girişimlerinden bir tanesi
boldu Ama içimde halen daha ise ben e
ticaret yapmak zorundayım gibi birtakım
fikirler var ve sürekli fikirler
üzerinde yanıp tutuşuyorum tabi Okulu
bitirdim Daha sonra master için nereye
gidebilirim hangi ülke uygun o sıralarda
da
çalışıyorum profesyonel olarak o arama
kartlarını getirdim hem de ya
Türkiye'deki büyük şirketlerde üst düzey
yönetici olarak çalışıyorum gittim genel
müdürüme gittim Dedim ki Ben dedim
Avustralya gitmeye karar verdim dedim
ama Dedi Bizde de şu bu şöyle büyük bir
bankanın şey birimine geçiyoruz
pazarlama biriminde geçiyoruz ve senin
için çok güzel bir kariyer planı olacak
Ben de dedim ki hani ben Evet bu benim
için büyük bir kariyer planı Olabilir
ama ben hayatıma farklı bir yön çizmek
istiyorum ve farklı bir açıdan
kendimi geliştirmek istiyorum ve bu
kendimi bambaşka bir kabusun ortasında
attım Orada iki tane şansım vardı ya
orada durup Başka bir firmanın büyümenin
kurumsal bir firmanın içerisinde
çalışacaktım ya da kendi maceramı aramak
için bu İlizyon ondan kurtulup bir
şekilde yurtdışına adım atacaktım
Avustralya Türkiye'den 25 bin kilometre
uzakta bir ülke ve orayı tercih etmem en
önemli sebebi
öğrencilere 20 saat haftalık 20 saat
çalışma izni veriyorlar ve bu çalışmayı
çerçevesinde yasal olarak hem okuyup
anda çalışabiliyor musunuz yapmadığım iş
kalmadı Türkiye'de kendi ülkemde üst
düzey yönetici iken ki Bu gelişme bir
şekilde başarmış Ken döndüm bambaşka bir
hayata sıfırdan başladım Birçok yerde
çalıştım garsonluk yaptım aşçılık yaptım
Yani aklınıza gelebilecek birçok işi
yaptım ve orada NBA bitirdim ve tekrar
ailemin tek kız olduğum için Türkiye'ye
geri döndüm oradaki hayatımda bıraktım
ve hala daha içimde aynı şeyler var Ben
daha fazla neler yapabilirim neler
yapabilirim aileme gittim Dedim ki ben
yedek parça sitesi kurmak istiyorum size
e-ticarette otomobil üzerine yedek
parçası kuracağım bana dediler ki yedek
parça bayan işi değil bunu yapamazsın Ya
ben işte mesleki de görmüyorum bu bayanı
şimdi erkek size görmüyor mu ayrımcılığa
giriyor ve bunun nedenlerini anlattım
anlattım yok dedi ama benim Çine gitmeme
izin verdi İçinde çok büyük bir yedek
parça fuar var ve ben Çin'e gitmeye
karar verdim aldım valizimi tekrar Çin'e
gittim Az önceki yedek parça
fabrikalarının dolaştım oradan neler
getirebiliriz hangi ürünler var
otomobillerle hangileri uyumlu ve
hangileri daha çok satılıyor bunların
araştırmasını yaptım sonra döndüm
Türkiye'ye dedim ki Bakın ben böyle
böyle çok ciddi bir pazar var burada
otomatik pazarı çok önemli bir pazar
Türkiye için çok çok Gelişmekte olan bir
pazar aynı zamanda işte kişi başına
düşen hane başına düşen otomobil
sayıları yükselecek Ve bu çok önemli bir
hal alacak Deza ki ama bayansın ve işte
bayan olmanın gerektirdiği bazı şeyler
var sorumluluklar var tamam dedim yine
başladım özel bir sektörde çalışmaya
tabi yönetici olarak çalışıyorum Öyleyse
gel zaman git zaman bütün
yöneticilikleri yaptıktan sonra bu sefer
köye gittim bu kim diye gitmemiz sebebi
tek Eş durumundan Fakat ben o sırada bir
danışmanlık şirketi kurdum eğitimi
veriyorum ve büyük şirketlere
danışmanlık yapan finansal Danışmanlık o
pazarlama danışmanlığı vesaire içimde
ama hep şey börek Ben Bu sektöre girmek
zorundayım ve nasıl gidelim en sonunda
gerekli sermaye birikimini bulaşık
ulaşınca
Türkiye'ye döndüm ve dedim ki ben Bu
sektöre giriş yapıyorum dediler ki olmaz
Gel sen işte plazmalarda çalıştın işte
Plaza insanlarına iş yapıyorsun Senin
çalıştığın kitle kurumsal buketli
kurumsal değil çok geleneksel bir sektör
yedek parça sektöründe inanılmaz
dinamikler var erkek Egemen bir sektör
bu sektörde çalışamazsın
Peki tamam bunları zaten biliyoruz
Bunlar senelerdir yaşadığım ve
senelerdir içinde
bulunduğu bulunduğu koşulları çok fazla
değerlendirdim ben yine de dedim ki ben
bütün bunlara razıyım böyle şey 15-20
metrekare bir bir metrekare bile değil
bir oda
bir yazılımcı bütün finansal planımı
yaptım kurumsal kimlik planı Ben her
şeyi yaptım Çünkü zaten hani pazarlama
eğitimi aldığım içine bütün bu planlama
mı yaptıktan sonra ben bu işe başladım
gel zaman git zaman tabi ilk satışımız
yaptık Ben böyle Aman Allahım dünyanın
en mutlu insanı falan oldum Çünkü
kimilerine göre zaten teknolojiye
yatırım yapmak manasızdı diğerlerine
göre bayan olmam benim için çok büyük
bir dezavantajlı başkalarına göre istek
Konfor alanımdan çıkmam bir kaos
ortamına girmem yanlıştı yanlışlar
üzerine
yola geldi zaten başarısız olacaktım ve
bu bir heves TV Bir Hayal de ve Ben
hayal kuruyordum Ben tabii ki satışını
yapınca dedim ki hayal kurmuyorum ya
bakın İşte yaptım bebek satışımı Neyse
bütün bunlara devam ederken
2015 senesinde
Altın Örümcek yılın Webo starları
ödülünü kazandık şık öyle bir ödül gibi
benim için Yani rakip bu Kırmız
inanılmaz büyük firmalar bizim Yani
bizim küçücük ofisimizde çalışanın 100
katı kişiler çalışıyor hepsi çok çok iyi
üniversitelerden mezun hepsi çok değerli
insanlar ve Biz bu ödülü aldığımızda
Gerçekten
inanılmaz bir motivasyon oldu yani Çünkü
öyle bir site kurmuştuk ki eşi benzeri
olmayan gerçekten yünek aracınızın tam
uyumlu parçalarını bulabileceğiniz
rahatlıkla alışveriş yapabileceğiniz bir
yedek parçası tespit ve bu ödülü aldı
Tabi ben çok mutluyum işte ödül aldık
falan filan Ee girişimcinin en büyük
problemin Ee tamam ödül alıyorsunuz ama
arkasından gelen bir şey finansman
gerekiyor ödül aldığında para mı kazandı
tabi girişimci için bu böyle 50 telaffuz
etmek kolay olmuyor Hayır işte daha
kazanacağız İnşallah vesaire gibi
Dolayısıyla uzun seneler bu şekilde Bu
bir roller coaster a binip iniş
çıkışlarla geçen bir girişim hikayesi
oldu ve günün sonunda
öğrendiğim en önemli şeylerden Bir
tanesi çok sabretmek çok çabalamak
karşındakini
sözlerine ne kadar değer versenizde
hayallerinizin peşinden gitmek ve asla
hayallerini ertelemek ve bütün bu
hayallerin yanı sıra onu yapabilmek için
Başka insanlara değer verdiğiniz ekip
Arkadaşlarınızı da hayallerinize
inandırmak zorundasınız Eğer bir
girişimde beklentiniz paraysa Bunu uzun
bir müddet unutmak zorundasınız Çünkü
finansla başarı aynı anda gelmiyor
özellikle teknolojiye yapılan yatırımlar
sürekli değiştiği için yaptığınız
yatırımları
kazandığınız süre boyunca sürekli
şirketinize yatırım yapmak zorunda
kalıyorsunuz ama Türkiye'de bir algıyı
kırdım ve bugün büyük firmaların reklam
bu
kaportada çalışan bayanların mekanikte
çalışan bayanların olduğunu görüyorum ve
bir bayan olarak bu girişimim ve çok
önemli bir şey değiştirdim kadın işe
erkek işi diye bir şey yoktur yaptığınız
işi tutkuyla yaptığınız sürece
hayatınızda katılabileceğiniz en büyük
anlam odur ve en büyük başarı olur
dolayısıyla örnek olmak topluma örnek
olmak kitleleri yönlendirmek kadınların
yapabileceği cinsiyet ayrımından uzak
yapabileceği şeyleri onlara göstermek ve
onlar için bir ışık olmak benim için
dünyanın en mutluluk verici şeyi ve
Dünya Kadınlar gününde olsun Başka
bayanların girişimlerinde olsun her
zaman ciddi anlamda örnek gösterilecek
bir noktaya geldik ve yedek parça işi
değil bütün işlerde bayanlar çabaladığı
sürece yaptığı işi sevdiği söz ve
tutkuyla sarıldığı sürece başarılı ve
dolayısıyla Eğer Hayal ediyorsanız
Sadece bunun peşinden gidin asla
bırakmayın sabredin ve bir gün o hayal
ettiğiniz şey kavuşacaksınız kıza
[Alkış]